we're gonna head in a different
direction here let me give you the
background i saw this clip
early this morning from the chris
collinsworth podcast featuring
richard sherman with john gruden the
raiders coach the guest i saw the clip
and i thought you know what i got enough
to worry about today
i got enough to deal with i got enough
people mad at me because
we made an issue out of the comments
that were made by devin white earlier
this week about
the the roots of a potential bounty
program
in tampa bay something that could grow
into that
in the future if they're not careful i
don't need
twitter harassing me any more than it
already does
i can't say i'm blameless i don't want
to be like antonio brown i kind of i
kind of troll twitter and i know what
i'm going to get
in response but i just decided i don't
want it i can't do it
and then i started hearing from
executives with other teams who saw the
same clip i did and they're like how can
you not write about this this
is a classic case of a blatant violation
of the rules here is the
exchange between collinsworth richard
sherman and john gruden
from the latest edition of the chris
collinsworth podcast
that's fine i've been punished very very
harshly but
sherman uh if you are a free agent which
there is a rumor you are
we are looking for an alpha presence in
our secondary
somebody that can play this hawk three
press technique with the reed step uh
if you're available and interested maybe
you and i can get together at some point
off here
yeah there's a conversation to be had
for sure um you know i am i'm free and
available these days
um fortunately and unfortunately
now we didn't play the part where chris
basically fires the warning shot in a
jovial way to john gruden
to keep him from getting himself into
trouble and when sims and i are
interviewing guys and
i've kind of had to reel sims in at
times because he'll
ask guys about players under contract
with other teams and he's learned he's
learned
you can't do it and we don't want to set
a trap for someone
and chris went out of his way to clear
the trap
off of the path and gruden ran into the
brush
and jumped in the trap with both feet
this is
as blatant an example of tampering
as i've ever seen because richard
sherman is not
a free agent he is not available
he remains exclusively in the employment
of the san francisco 49ers until march
17
at 401 pm eastern period
and even though it seemed like it was
light-hearted and joking
it is still a classic
textbook-defined violation shireen
of the tampering world the nfl don't do
anything about this they should just rip
up the rule and throw it away
and there's no question about that mike
and again we link players right you're
already
linking richard sherman to las vegas
because of his relationship with gus
bradley so he's already been linked
there
and it is blatant and you know this is
another example of the raiders and john
gruden just
basically laughing in the face of the
nfl and it's rule book
i mean they're already appealing that
six round pick they lost
coming up for this spring because of the
continued violations of the coronavirus
protocols we saw it again and again and
again repeatedly during the season
we saw john gruden get fined during the
season for that so this is just another
example mike of
of the raiders kind of just throwing the
rule book into the nfl's face and saying
we're going to do whatever we want to do
so they do need to be penalized for this
otherwise just let everybody talk about
every player on another team at all
times
yeah and look every time i raise this
issue i will have
the pushback from those who will say i'm
being the hall monitor
why are you snitching look there are
rules they either have meaning
or they don't if they don't have meaning
if they're not going to be applied get
rid of them and
chiefs fans may remember that there was
an occasion five or six years ago
where andy reid spoke to jeremy macklin
who had become a free agent or was about
to become a free agent with the eagles
during the window where it was
permissible to speak to the agent
but not directly to the player andy reid
spoke directly to the player
and the chiefs got hammered for it they
appealed
the penalty was reduced a little bit but
i still think they lost a third round
pick over it yeah
so if you're going to hit the chiefs for
andy reid having a conversation directly
with the player that he drafted
and he had extensive conversations with
in philadelphia
on the eve of free agency how can you
look the other way
when john gruden is blatantly violating
disregarding and ignoring the tampering
rules
on the record in a public conversation
sharing how can you can't reconcile the
two
yeah you can't ignore it mike if you're
the nfl you just absolutely can it just
opens the pandora's box if you do ignore
it
so i think they need to lose a draft
pick at minimum here
maybe some cash too on the side whatever
the penalty is that the nfl wants to
enforce
they need to enforce it and it doesn't
matter if the 49ers have no intent
in bringing back richard sherman it
doesn't matter if sherman has no intent
in rejoining the 49ers
it doesn't matter if the 49ers don't
even make a complaint
with the league it is hiding in plain
sight the league doesn't like to flag
for the rest of us hey there's a cheater
over here hey there's a cheater over
there
sometimes the league is forced to act
when something this blatant happens this
is on john gruden and whatever the
punishment is
it is entirely and exclusively his
responsibility
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports